I learned something about you and I'd  like to have a conversation with you  yeah because it hurt me it hurt you what  what can I say what it is oh okay my  wound yeah  and I really um I'm really emotional  about it really to be honest with you  you're emotional I'm emotional how tough  you are keep going what do you mean I  feel like there's a sneaking don't make  me laugh okay what kind of face is this  is the sneaky face or real emotion I  think it's not a genuine face he's  making right now it's like nostrils  flared trying it he's that face where he  just wants to poke yeah poke it to get a  ride  it's not a fog you look Pokey okay hey  you're feeling a little Pokey look at me  I Pokey